well John the ACLU demanding an
investigation into Nye County's
controversial hand counting of ballots 8
news now the only local television
station to get a first-hand look at that
process which was eventually shut down
investigator Vanessa Murphy is here with
the latest
well Denise when we observed the hand
counting last Thursday there was a woman
named Laura who was helping run things
at the front desk in the rooms where the
votes were being counted helping
volunteers with questions we thought she
was a County employee a spokesman
telling me today she is not the ACLU now
demanding an investigation into this
saying she's actually the vice chair of
the Nye County Republican party reps
from the ACLU say when they observed on
Wednesday she removed one of them while
openly carrying a firearm which we saw
also and that's allowed and demanded the
ACLU Observer turn over their notes now
at the time the ACLU also thought she
was an employee
some background here in March Nye County
Commissioners asked the clerk then to
implement paper ballots that clerk
resigned comp who had previously said
Trump won the 2020 election took over he
insisted to me on Thursday his politics
are not involved in how he's running the
clerk's office the hand count began last
Wednesday was shut down Thursday evening
after a decision by the Nevada Supreme
Court that the process did not comply
with orders to protect early voting
results now just today clerk Mark comp
told me a new proposal for a hand count
using a different process was submitted
to the Secretary of State's office for
approval I asked him to send that to me
he said no we have more on this story at
8newsnow.com back to you